لكن ما هو مصطلح الاسلحه النوويه
التكتيكيه المصطلح يشير الى تلك التي
تستخدم لتحقيق مكاسب محدده في ساحه
المعركه خلافا للاسلحه القادره على اباده
المدن فالاسلحه التكتيكيه مشاهدينا مصممه
لانجاز هدف عسكري محدود وفوري وليس
الانتصار في معركه ما ويتم في كثير من
الاوقات استخدام المصطلح لوصف الاسلحه
الاقل في القوه او كميه الطاقه المنطلقه
خلال الانفجار في الاغلب تكون الاسلحه
التكتيكيه على شكل صاروخ او قنابل يتم
اسقاطها من الجو او حتى قذائف مدفعيه كما
نشاهد ذات مدى قصير نسبيا بخلاف طبعا
الرؤوس التقليديه التي تحمل على صواريخ
عابره للقارات اما عن القوه التدميريه
لهذه القنابل فت بين قنبله واخرى القدره
التدميريه لاصغر سلاح نووي تكتكي تصل الى
كيلو طن واحد اي ما يعادل 1000 طن من ماده
تي ان تي المتفجره في حين قد يصل حجم
اكبرها الى مئه كيلو طن وفيما يتعلق بعدد
الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه عالميا فيصعب
يصعب تحديد الارقام الدقيقه لها لان الدول
على اختلافها لا تنشر ارقاما حول عدد هذه
القنابل لكن وفقا لارقام صادره من مركز
ابحاث تمتلك الولايات المتحده ما يقرب من
230 سلاحا نوويا غير استراتيجي منها قنابل
يجري نشرها على طائرات في اوروبا بينما
تمتلك روسيا حوالي 2000 سلاح نووي تكتيكي
وعلى المستوى العالمي تمتلك كل من الصين
وكوريا الشماليه والهند ايضا اسلحه نوويه
تكتيكيه